oui alors effectivement faut d'abord
rappeler que la station c'est une
situation où on a de manière combinée
une inflation forte et une croissance
nulle ou extrêmement faible alors
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le risque le
plus évident pour deux raisons la
première raison c'est que évidemment on
voit bien qu'il ya des causes techniques
à cette inflation et puis la deuxième
raison c'est que y'a toujours un chômage
qui est assez important en particulier
en france mais c'est quand même aussi
vrai largement en europe et tant qu'il y
aura ce chômage
on peut penser qu'il n'y aura pas de
cesse d'en voler des salaires et des
coûts salariaux
et des français qui devrait faire face à
une hausse des prix qui s'accélère dans
le pays avec un pic de plus de 1,9 pour
cent en août du jamais vu en trois ans
l'inflation un phénomène général en
cette période de reprise parce qu vide
alors comment expliquer cette poussée
soudaine des prix cette flambée est elle
une menace pour le pouvoir d'achat quels
sont les risques de stagflation
c'est-à-dire l'inflation sans croissance
une fois l'euphorie de la reprise
passait on voit c'est tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est notre
rubrique l'édito échos
et bonsoir jacques merci d'être avec
nous alors cette inflation dont on parle
est ce que finalement c'est un phénomène
purement français où ça concerne
d'autres pays également alors oui vous
avez tout à fait raison de parler de
stagflation au départ non c'est un
phénomène général on le voit par exemple
au niveau des états unis qui sont
actuellement à 5 4% d'inflation s'ils
voulaient c'est énorme parce que il
était pratiquement à zéro au mois de
janvier on le voit en europe dans
l'union européenne
ou on est pour les prix industriels
autour de 2,3 pour cent et on le voit
aussi en france avec un taux d'environ
1,9 pour cent alors un jacques pour la
france donc quelle est la situation
précisément alors pourront là pour la
france s'ils voulaient la situation
c'est la suivante on n'a eu pratiquement
une inflation qui a fortement baissé
dans l'année 2020 et qui a commencé à
redémarrer à partir de janvier février
de cette année alors ça peut se
comprendre on a eu les de confinement de
2020 ça a évidemment casser complètement
l'activité ce qui est quand même
intéressant c'est de voir que quand
l'inflation repart le troisième
confinement ne l'affectent pas et
évidemment depuis la sortie du 3ème
confinement là l'inflation suivant les
chiffres de l'insee accélère et comme je
le disais elle atteint maintenant 1,9
pour cent alors quels sont les produits
qui ont le plus contribué à cette
inflation alors comme en europe qui a
évidemment une hausse assez sensible des
produits industriels mais ce qui est
intéressant dans le cas de la france
c'est de voir que les produits agricoles
les produits alimentaires aussi ont une
remontée de manière assez conséquente
est là encore si on se réfère à l'insee
il y à une hausse d'environ 10% mais je
dirais à partir d'un niveau qui est
effectivement très bas au départ
d'environ 10% depuis sept huit mois donc
là aussi il y a un effet d'inflation qui
étrennait évidemment la question qu'on
pose pourquoi de telles hausses oui
évidemment c'est une question qu'on veut
se poser alors d'abord il faut savoir il
y à des ruptures de production plus
précisément la demande est repartie
beaucoup plus vite koné repartiez la
production sa cause des phénomènes de
pénurie et ses piques brive dame en font
monter les prix c'est le cas
particulièrement des semi conducteurs il
ya aujourd'hui plusieurs usines en
allemagne et en france qui sont au
chômage technique à cause de cette
question après il ya un problème global
de hausse des matières premières et sa
touche et ça c'est intéressant toutes
les matières premières qu'il s'agisse
des matières premières agricoles
problème en france mais qu'il s'agisse
aussi du pétrole qui est passé de
environ 40 dollars le baril au début de
cette année à 70 dollars actuellement et
les métaux enfin il ya un problème que
l'on a tendance à négliger mais qui est
très important c'est la désorganisation
des modes de transports la
désorganisation de la logistique il ya
des porcs qui ont été bloqués à cause de
la crise de la queue vide en chine en
particulier et on voit que le prix du
transport est en train d'augmenter très
fortement alors c'est intéressant
effectivement mais vous ne parlez pas de
la politique des banques centrales est
ce qu'elle aurait quelque chose à voir
maintenant je vous vois venir
effectivement la politique des banques
centrales elle joue mais elle ne joue
pas sur cette inflation elle va jouer
beaucoup plus sur l'inflation de ce
qu'on appelle les actifs patrimoniaux
alors lancé des actifs patrimoniaux
évidemment les actions les obligations
et on voit bien aujourd'hui le marché de
paris comme l'ensemble des marchés
financiers est un des plus hauts
historiques
mais ça touche aussi par exemple le prix
des logements et là un phénomène qui est
assez intéressant on voit que bon double
que ce soit les les appartements ou les
maisons tout cela ça a monté depuis sept
huit mois aujourd'hui les appartements
stagne voire reubess un petit peu
pourquoi parce que les gens à cause des
confinement se disent on n'a pas envie
d'être confiné dans un appartement on
veut pouvoir acheter une maison si
possible avec un petit terrain pour que
les gosses puissent jouer etc et là on
voit que le prix des maisons augmentent
de manière très sensible alors on en
parlait tout à l'heure est ce qu'il ya
un risque de stagflation
clairement aujourd'hui comme certains le
redoutent et on en parlait oui alors
effectivement il faut d'abord rappeler
que la stagflation c'est une situation
où on a de manière combinée une
inflation forte et une croissance nulle
ou extrêmement faible alors aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le risque le plus évident
pour deux raisons la première raison
c'est que évidemment on voit bien qu'il
ya des causes techniques à cette
inflation et puis la deuxième raison
c'est que il ya toujours un chômage qui
est assez important en particulier en
france mais c'est quand même aussi vrai
largement en europe et tant qu'il y aura
ce chômage on peut penser qu'il n'y aura
pas de cesse d'en voler des salaires et
des coûts salariaux maintenant l'autre
problème c'est que cette inflation est
elle détériore le pouvoir d'achat et en
particulier le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés les plus faibles parce qu'il
faut bien voir que dans la hausse
moyenne des salaires que l'on a connu
malgré tout malgré l'épidémie eh bien
elle est tirée par les salaires les plus
élevés et les salaires du médian
inférieur autrement dit elles qui sont
inférieurs à la moitié et bien soit ils
sont restés sable soit ils ont baissé
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire bien ça
veut dire que le gouvernement va être
sous une pression très forte d'une part
pour augmenter de manière substantielle
le smic et puis d'autre part et ça c'est
aussi un problème qu'il faut relier je
dirais aux pénuries de main-d'oeuvre
qu'on a sectoriellement à si vous voulez
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'entreprise qui
soit aujourd'hui en france bloquée par
manque de main d'oeuvre mais on a des
pénuries qui sont qui peuvent apparaître
de manière relative sectoriellement est
né il va y avoir nécessairement une
hausse des salaires dans les mois qui
viennent l'inflation donc à surveiller
comme le lait sur le fonctionnement avec
vous jacques sapir merci à vous et à
très bientôt